We feel that we're finding ourselves
in the middle of a generation. And, um,
maybe even at the beginning of an era
where we struggled to sit down and have a
difficult conversation oftentimes,
um,
I don't believe that echo chambers force
you to interrogate your own beliefs.
Um, and censorship doesn't
foster personal growth,
but I believe that these things can only
be accomplished through conversation,
through civil discourse, which is exactly
what we're hoping to do here tonight.
We're hoping to reestablish a culture
of conversation on this campus where
neighbors can disagree off into
the core of their beliefs, um,
and stand out from that conversation,
stand up from that table and walk away
and still come together knowing that
we're all part of the same community
that were all wildcats. Um,
and so with that, uh, we invite
you attorney point invites you,
everyone here from the left
of the aisle to the right,
the front of the room to the back,
everyone in here and outside
to join in this conversation,
in this conversation and all conversations
moving forward to have an open mind,
open ears in the willingness
to participate in civil
discussion. Um, with that,
I'd like you ask,
do you want me put your hands together
for the host of the Rubin report?
Dave Rubin.
[inaudible]
thank you guys. Wow. I
got to tell you guys,
I did not think my day was going to end
up in a hockey rink when I woke up this
morning. But here we are, uh, any hockey
fans here? We have some hockey pads.
All right. All right.
I am wearing a cop, uh,
because it's a free speech or Banta and
you know, I know what's going to happen.
All right.
I mean this is kind of crazy.
First off I asked him if we're
going to do this at a hockey rink,
can I come in on the Zamboni?
But apparently
they didn't turn any point. Doesn't
have the money for that kind of thing.
Unfortunately.
That's tough little you guys,
you all came out here to a hockey rink.
So listen to me talk about free speech.
That's pretty cool. I'm very
excited. You guys put on good.
Nice.
There's more outside.
I think we have room.
There might be a seat
back there somewhere.
I think we could probably let anymore,
I mean it's kind of fitting
that this is sort of how uh,
we ended up right at a hockey rink
right now if you think about it, I mean,
you know, uh, all the,
all the officers and policemen
that are here securing this thing,
these guys are doing their jobs,
doing a great job.
Actually give them a round of applause
for [inaudible],
making sure that nothing
crazy going to happen.
I guarantee you you're not gonna hear
anything remotely close to hate speech or
anything like that.
There actually is no such thing as hate
speech and we'll talk about that too.
But you're not going to hear any hate
out of me. I guarantee you, uh, you know,
Candace Irwin's who, uh, seven words
really put her on the map this week.
I love the way Candace Owens thinks
from Kanye and just seemingly has,
has the world.
I
actually think, uh, putting aside what
your feelings are, I'm Kanye for a moment.
I think that him saying that offering
a little oxygen for people that want to
think a little bit differently,
just a little bit differently.
If you don't want to just take democratic
dogma or leftist dog more progressive
dogma if you don't want to take that
as the Bible, as the word from God,
that you need a little room to think
differently and I think you guys probably
do think a little bit differently.
I hope we have,
I can see some interesting diversity.
The left loves diversity,
meaning the color of your skin and your
sexuality and all that stuff and your
gender and that's all
that's all well and fine,
but that's actually not
the diversity that matters.
The diversity of the matters is
what's going on in your head.
What do you actually think,
right?
I mean imagine if I was to look
at you guys and I can just pay.
I mean I can look any of you and
think, all right, white guy there.
He must think that black guy there,
he must think that Asian girl there,
she must think that that actually
is the essence of prejudice, okay?
That is the essence of prejudice.
Prejudice, which means to prejudge.
And if you look at someone and think
that you know what they should think
because of the color of their skin
or their sexuality or anything else,
you actually, you're the one that
is acting bigoted. I mean that's,
that's actually the truth that sort of
the reverse of how it's spun these days,
but the only way that we can
actually have conversations,
the only way that we can actually figure
out what's going on and figure out how
can we really talk to each other is
if you look at people as individuals,
not as a collective,
and this is Kinda the key to everything
that sort of wrong with society right
now. We've somehow figured out
that if we group each other right,
if we grew each other and we play this
really awful game of identity politics,
that's really the reverse of everything
that this nation was founded upon.
You know, think about this for
a second. You guys are here,
University of New Hampshire.
I assume most of you go to the
university or you're at a great school.
I guarantee that virtually every single
one of you have it better than your
grandparents or your great grandparents.
Virtually every if really think about it.
Think about your grandparents
for a second. Think about
your great grandparents.
Probably didn't know them.
I guarantee you what you have
at 19 2021 years old, however,
however old you are, is, is a lot better.
It's a world better than the way they
had it. No matter what color you are,
religion you are or anything,
and this is what identity
politics has put us up against.
It's placed us in this situation where
we're grouping people based on their
immutable characteristics. So if
you're black, you should think this.
If you're Muslim, you should
think this. If you're gay,
you should think this and this,
which really, as you guys know,
this is what intersectionality
is all about.
The idea behind intersectionality being
that if you take all of these groups,
you can kind of put them together like a
transformer or something and that there
will become something stronger.
But actually what's been
proven and everything that's
happening in society right
now is that they're becoming weaker.
They're actually in a sort of oppression
Olympics where they're competing
with each other for victimhood and,
and victim hood is not virtue. And
that's really important. You know,
what's virtue guys?
It's what the motto of this state is.
Live free or die down,
whatever.
[inaudible]
yeah,
I mean that's kind of depressing about
the fact that we had to switch your menus
here. I mean the state motto is live free
or die or he goes live free or go to a
hockey rink. Um, but that's
what virtue is. Living for dye.
Figure out what you believe.
What do you believe and fight for
that relentlessly fight for that.
Even by the end of this thing.
And we'll do a robust Q and a and I'm
happy to hear from any of you guys that
disagree with me on all this stuff.
Whatever you believe,
if you fight for it honestly and,
and using your mind and your faculties
and not because you silence people are
because you pulled fire alarms are called
in bomb threat if you fight for that.
I agree. Black lives do
matter. Tate, I'm with Ya.
Good. Gotcha. Okay.
Can someone shut off the robot?
I don't know how we're going to do this,
right guys. I got you. We're glad to it.
Do you think anyone's here for you guys?
Is that what you think?
What's going on here guys?
I like this guy more. Listen
guys guys, guys, guys,
do you think anyone's here for you?
Do you understand what you're doing right
now? Hey listen, listen, listen guys,
guys, guys, look at me. Look at me. I mean
you can at least look at me. There you go.
All right, look, look, look, look.
Do you think anyone's here for you?
I agree. Black lives matter. I agree.
Black lives matter.
Do you know how to play the quiet game
or we'll try it that way guys. Guys,
you listen,
you got the script down.
I'm an impress too with the repetition
and today I'm coming. You know
guys?
Yeah, let's try this. I see some
black people in the audience could,
could someone ask them to be quiet?
Would that maybe work guys guys,
come on.
Thank you sister guys.
Guys. Guys, you are.
What is wrong with this right now?
You, you are proving it right now.
You are proving it right now.
This nonsensical guys,
this epic,
nonsensical self. Righteous
Bullshit. Sit down.
Sit down. Yeah, I know.
Yell Louder. Oh God.
Get laid. Like go do something
with your eyes. So pathetic.
No one's here for you.
You know what?
I'll give you a cookie if you can
say something else. How about that?
I got a whole tray of cookies back
there. No. Yeah. Do you think,
I don't think black lives
matter. What? What are you going?
She's checking her phone to make sure she
got the script right. Okay. Come on now.
Come on. You can do it. You could do
it may take a seat. Make us eat. Yeah.
Okay. Remember guys,
we're the intolerant ones.
We are the intolerant ones,
right?
Do you know you can see all you
guys getting real violent on them.
You know nobody's here for them.
But guys,
what are we gonna do about this?
Alright. Alright. Five more.
Five more. Four, three,
two,
one.
But I really thought you were with me
on that. Um, okay. All right, hold on.
I can do this. I can do
this. Um, guy, seriously.
Shut the fuck up. Shut the
fuck up. It's pathetic.
You're pathetic. Human beings.
Really. I'm all about open exchange.
This is what I do for a living.
I will gladly take all your
questions all night long.
You are what is wrong with society?
You said right there you are.
What's wrong with society and you ma'am,
you're what's wrong with society?
Yeah. Hey man, needs to hear.
Yeah. I don't want to kick these guys
out. I know the police are happy to kick.
Do you guys out?
Oh Wow.
Just refresh me for a sec. What
were you saying again? Cause I,
yeah, just relax. Relax. Okay.
I believe black lives matter.
I believe every life matters.
I believe that we should not be
prejudice towards everyone. Anyone.
And we should not have laws that are
dictated that are different for anyone.
That we should be treating everyone equal.
That is the beauty of America.
I'm going to talk to
my friends right here.
The beauty of this country is that people
from every walk of life have come here
no matter the color of their skin or
their religion or whatever they came with.
Look what it says on the, on the Statue
of Liberty. You know what I mean?
She didn't say bring us your best.
She said, bring us your poor,
your huddled masses,
and you know what's happened because
of the incredible freedoms that we have
given people in this country. Everyone
look around this room. This is diversity,
but it's, as I said earlier,
it's not just diversity of color,
it's diversity of thought.
And I'm going to come up here,
I'm going to talk about a lot of things
that the conservatives aren't happy
about and conservative
groups invite me to do that.
So I appreciate that you've quieted down
and if you grant me the same respect
that I'll grant you. That's how
you change things. But that,
that what you just did there right there,
that's not how you change
things is how you change things.
Just not change things for the better
anyway. How's it going on this ad guys?
Anyone want to get
anything off their chest.
So this scourge of identity politics,
it truly,
it truly is rotting away
at everything that's right.
With this country. The country was founded
on the idea of the melting pot, right?
That you come here from wherever you came,
wherever you came,
more people have come to America,
make a better life for themselves and
any place in the history of the world.
That is absolutely true. Does that mean
it's perfect? No. Does that mean we don't,
we've made mistakes. Absolutely. Does
that mean that there are injustices now?
Of course, but there is no place which
is why no one ever leaves. All right.
Are any of you guys planning on
leaving America? Yeah. Nobody goes.
Even Lena Dunham, she's still
here. It would be nice if she left,
but she's still here. Okay. Nobody
leaves and this is the irony.
So you have this set of people now who
go on and on about identity politics and
everything that's wrong with America
and where this evil Patriarchy and where
this evil, racist society and they
demand at the same time. I love this one.
They demand at the same time that we
should have open borders so that I guess
the other people can share in the horrors
that are America. That is not sensible.
You see what I'm saying?
It's not sensible people.
What is sensible is coming
together regardless of what
your differences are and
the only way you do that is if you view
people as individuals that every single
one of you that I can look at you right
there looking at me with the glasses.
You, we were, we were having a moment
there. You're looking away from me. Okay.
I'll look at somebody else. How
you doing buddy? Right here.
The only way I can judge you, I know
nothing about you, nothing about you.
I know nothing about you,
but all I can figure out is
that if we had a conversation,
I could figure out what you
think and why you think it.
And hopefully if you thought some
things that I thought were wrong through
civility,
I could get you to think differently
and perhaps you could get me to think
differently. So let's talk about
some of our differences actually,
because turning point invites me to
all of these things and Charlie has no
problem being on stage with me and
we have plenty of differences. I am,
I'm for gay marriage. I even married
a dude. I mean that's a, yeah,
I'm gay. Okay. Zippity Damn Dude.
I thought I was going to get an applause
from my impression, but you know,
all right. Um, yeah, it doesn't matter.
It just doesn't matter what you
should want or equal rights.
So any of you can marry whoever you
want to marry. You want equal rights,
that's all you want.
You don't want extra eyes.
The conservatives in
invite me to these places.
I'm what I would describe
as begrudgingly pro choice.
I think it's a horrible
decision to have to make,
I know two women in the last year in my
life who had to have abortions or who
chose to have abortions. I know this
is for the conservative. This is,
this is a bridge too far.
And I've had plenty of people on my show.
I had a debate with Ben Shapiro about
abortion and you know, I've picked a
20 weeks as the,
I like where this one's going.
Oh,
is that rain? Is that we're, we're,
I'm gonna need a little more on that one.
Yeah.
Is this a local thing?
What's going on? Do you want,
you want to ask me something? Yeah, you
could ask me something. See, this is the,
this is what happens every time. Truly,
ma'am, if you want to ask me something,
I'd love to hear a question in front
of you for no. So you don't have a did,
is there anything I said they get
in like did you not like anything?
You don't want to comment on that either.
You see what's going on here?
I really want you guys to understand
this because this is so consistent.
We can get some robots and
clones here, which, you know,
repeating some stuff and
now you have a jar with a,
whatever the hell you got in there.
And I'm,
I am seriously willing to
have a conversation with
you right now. Let's do it.
Let's do it.
But you won't question me.
And you won't tell me you didn't
like anything. Who's winning here?
Do you think right now who's
changing more minds? Me Or you?
Yeah, I think, I think I made my
point. All right. Yeah. No, it's here.
He's got some move over here.
It's not true.
What they say about white
people can't dance. I saw that.
That was very impressive.
He had that two white guys have two moves,
like a shoulder thing and a hip
thing. All right. All right.
Put your little toy away. Uh, God. Yeah.
Well that's what I put this. But see,
this is what's happened.
This is what has led us here to the irony.
This is so ironic,
you guys don't remember this,
but 10 years ago when you guys
were whatever you were, 10, 11,
12 years old, the conservatives
were the intolerant side.
The conservatives were the ones that were
screaming against gay marriage and the
conservatives who were the one talking
about all sorts of other stuff that was
actually intolerant.
This is intolerant now and you don't
get extra credit for your skin color.
And I hate to tell Ya. So, I
mean, that's just how it is.
I would love to have a conversation with
you and you want to rattle around a can.
Okay, so that's fine. But this is what
has happened. You guys, the conservatives,
the conservative. Well, how many of you
actually consider yourself conservative?
It make some noise, makes her eyes. If you
consider yourself close to a park, yeah.
Good for you guys.
You're going to have jobs in the future.
You're gonna have cars and family and
property and things, and it's pretty good.
That's sweet. All right. How many of
you consider yourself a libertarian?
Any Libertarians you can,
you can do make noise instead of clapping.
You're all very respectful here.
Yeah. All right, libertarians,
you're going to smoke a lot of
pot. That's great. That's great.
You're going to argue about whether
driver's license, it should be real.
I love Libertarians. I mean really
fundamentally, I think I'm probably,
although we're going to talk about
classical liberalism in a second,
I think actually more than anything,
I'm a libertarian in that I want you
to live free and I want to live free.
And the only exchange that we can have
there is that basically I'm going to have
my stuff.
You're going to have your stuff and you
can't just come onto my property and
take my shit. As long as we'd get that
fun. That's a pretty good society.
And that means that occasionally people
are gonna say things that upset you.
That means that people are going
to do things that upset you.
But that's the beauty of this thing.
You know,
there are some societies where nobody's
gonna say anything that upsets you.
You know where that is. That's North
Korea. You don't want to be there.
You don't want to be there. You are
going to be upset every now and again,
but you know what?
Words are not violence.
I know that the left has tried to trick
you into thinking that because somebody
says something that upsets you,
that you're either allowed to punch them
or silence or call in a bomb threat or
force a venue to have to move,
but that is not. You are right.
You have the right to free speech
and you are right to free speech.
The whole purpose of your rights to
free speech is that you have to respect
someone else's right to free speech. Now
what you can do by the way, is protest.
I hope that there, thank you. I hope
that there are protesters are, are,
are war protesters out there with as many
signs as they want to have doing their
thing.
And as long as you do it peacefully
and you don't encroach on anyone else's
rights, that's, you're supposed to do
that in a free society. It's beautiful.
But if you use your free speech
to infringe on somebody else's,
you're actually not part
of civil society at all.
So all right, back to the libertarian.
So I liked the libertarians.
I voted for Gary Johnson.
I had Gary Johnson on my show.
He didn't know his name. He wasn't
the best candidate ever. Um,
Aleppo, he just, yeah, not
a, not a great candidate.
He was the first guy that ever turned me
against weed cause he couldn't remember
if I can thing. I mean he really was
just a terrible, terrible candidate.
This would've been the year.
Right now it's 2016 would have been
the year for a libertarian candidate.
I mean we had to have what I would
say are the worst candidates in,
in at least as candidates.
We can talk about Trump in a second,
but at least it's candidates.
We had two of the worst,
most polarizing candidates ever and all
the libertarian had to do was come in
and understand some basic shit
and Gary just dropped the ball.
He just,
every interview it was like watching
a muppet right out of put it in.
It's too easy to beat up on him,
so forget Gary dies. All right.
How many of you guys consider yourselves
classical liberals? Classical liberals.
All right. A couple of classical
liberals, they're very respectful.
That's what I like. Um,
so classical liberalism,
this is interesting because people say
to me, well, what's the difference, Dave?
You say you're a classical liberal and
how is that different than being on the
left? How is that different than being
a progressive and a classical liberal?
Basically?
It's really simple.
If you believe in the individual
that I was talking about before.
If you believe that the
government has some role to exist,
that the government has to do something,
but not everything.
So our founders actually, mostly,
I think we're classical liberals,
are founders basically
create an incredible system
where we have 50 states now
and we have a federal government
that should do very little.
The federal government should
make sure that, you know,
they're taking care of our borders.
They should make sure that our states
aren't warring with each other.
But beyond that, the federal government
actually shouldn't do that much.
That if you believe in that, if you
believe there's some role for government,
but not some massive
government that we have,
then I think you're basically
a classical liberal.
So the classical liberals
in the libertarians are
pretty much in the same spot.
And ironically now the conservatives have
sorta come in and fit into that thing
as well. So there's a pretty big
tent developing on the right.
While the left is just purging
every one of their free thinkers.
I mean every one of them.
Look what happened to Kanye this week.
Forget what you think about Kanye.
Forget what you think. His politics are.
Any of you like his music or not? It's
completely irrelevant. Look what happened.
He tweets seven words about a relative,
a girl that I know and like a lot but it,
but a relatively unknown person in
Candice Owens and suddenly everybody,
the lead story on Twitter
moments was Kanye West.
Tweets support for far right
Candace Owens far right candidates.
Owens a a black girl who happens to
be a conservative. It's now far right?
All right.
Yeah, I'm with you. Solidarity
against hate. I am with Ya.
I'm with you guys. Yeah, you
guys working with these two?
You guys are definitely hang out with
them because I think it would be fun.
Um, I'm doing, I'm with
Ya. I'm with you guys.
Solidarity against hate.
I don't think you should hate anyone based
on their sexuality or their eye. Lord.
Alright. Yeah. Alright,
here we go. Here we go.
Yeah, they, they messed up the rhythm on
that one. I caught that. All right. Yeah,
I got you guys. Yeah.
Let me, let's try this.
How many of you here are for hate?
How many of you are for
hate is anyone for hate?
If we're at a hate rally here as they
would have us believe anyone for hate.
Nobody for it. Guys, do you
think you're helping your, cause
this is what I'm trying to tell you. Do
you think you're helping your cause here?
Do you have any questions for
me? I'll gladly, no, no question.
You just made a point. We're going to let
it be all right. There you go. Pay Off.
We do the mic. So we were going to
offer the mic for this nonsense. Um,
this, this is what the
problem is. You guys see this.
I mean you really need to grasp
yourselves around this and,
and why does this keep happening?
Why does this sort of endless droning
and repetitive sort of pointless
statements. Everyone's against hate.
Everyone that's sensible is against hate.
But why does this keep happening?
And there's a reason it keeps happening
because leftism and progressivism and
collectivism grouping people by
those immutable characteristics,
it has been so ingrained and taught to
you guys at colleges and it has been so
rewarded by the mainstream media
and it has been coddled. You've, oh,
you guys have been coddled to think that
what you think automatically has to be
right in that all the people that came
before you had no fucking clue as to what
they were doing. But some of
them did. Some of them did.
Some of them had bad ideas and
some of them had good ideas.
And some people in this room have
bad ideas and some have good ideas,
but just chanting things because
you're upset actually has no meaning.
And that's why I still,
when we do the Q and a at the end,
I will gladly go to you guys first if
you can come up with an original thought
and, and tell me what you think of
something. But that, but that's the truth.
That's that sadly is the truth.
And that's why oddly,
the right now is the home for
free thinking. I'm shocked.
This was completely not what
I ever thought would happen,
but yet that is where we are right now.
What's that? What do you got for me?
She's Mauldin something at me. What do
you got? What do you got? Oh No. Yeah,
not bad, you know, turn it,
combat jet.com. Okay. Um,
I don't even, I don't get like a referral
fee on that or anything. That's uh,
that's just the truth,
but okay.
So this idea of identity
politics has wreck things.
I want to give you a couple of examples
of how it has done this. So, uh,
I assume most of you have
seen some of my shows,
at least I want to mention a couple
of my guests. So Jordan Peterson,
how many of you guys know Jordan Peterson?
Okay.
Jordan Peterson,
for those of you that don't know him,
he was a psychology professor
at the University of Toronto
for the past 30 years
or so. He's done tremendous
academic work for many years.
Really wasn't a public person.
He had written one book a couple of
years back and about two years ago,
Canada was going to pass.
It wasn't quite going to be a law,
it was going to sort of be a directive.
But we know how these things sort of
operate. It starts with, you know,
some subtle thing and then eventually
becomes a law that if you miss gendered,
somebody you could be fined.
And then potentially this would
lead to imprison minutes on point.
Now let's be very clear.
Here I am 100% for
equality for trans people.
Jordan, who I know extremely well. We're
going on tour together. I'm not what,
okay,
I got no, I got no problem with you. I
don't know what you're talking about.
I have trans friends. Uh, I dunno what,
what do you mean? I, I think you should
there.
Yeah. Well it's all right. I'm
only gay after 10 is that right?
Whoa. Whoa. So, all right.
All right, let's do it.
You seem to have thought so that's
pretty good. So what have I said that is,
that is so offensive to you.
I am 100% for you to have the same
exact dignity that everyone else in this
country as I am 100%
for you to have every,
every law and legal protection that
anyone else in this country has.
So what is it that you don't, uh,
want me to say that I have said here?
Wow.
Well, I was about to get to that until you
started screaming. Yeah. All right, well,
you know what? Here's the thing. We have
a right to free speech. You don't have it.
Hang on. Hang on. Listen. Okay, I got Ya.
I got Ya. Okay, so real. You know what?
Here's the deal in, in free
western societies, you have
the right to free speech.
You don't, you don't have the
right to not be offended. Now,
I am not for people running down the
street and and saying anything hateful to
you, but really think about
what you're calling for here.
Think about what you're calling for here.
What you're saying is that if
someone walking down the street says,
Miss Miss Genders,
you right that you want this
person to be fined or put in jail,
that's what you think is right.
Is that, is that correctly?
I don't want put words in your mouth.
You're right. And you know how people
should be held accountable by themselves,
by their family, by their friends, by
their community, not the government.
And this was again was the government.
But see how I already got you
to move on your position there.
I think anyone can understand that you
wouldn't want the government coming in
and telling people what you can
and cannot say. So Jordan said,
I am not against Trans people and
it's very clear to me that he's not
there at this flat. Finally,
someone making some sense out there.
So you really need to understand this.
You don't,
you don't have a right to be not offended.
I wish we all wish that we lived in a
better place where magically everybody was
wonderful, where magically
everyone was sweet and decent.
We don't live in that world.
But if you think that the government
forcing people to do to act as you wish
they would act is going to bring
peace and love and harmony,
it actually will only bring the complete
reverse every time in the history of
the world that the
government promised utopia,
it brought dystopia every time that
the government expanded to create some
magical society, it brings societies
that kill millions of people.
So what you should want is exactly
what you have in America right now,
which is that you have equality. You,
you can have a job, you can live free.
I hope you have someone in
your life that you love.
You can have all of those things.
And if the government started cracking
down on you because you happen to be
trans, I will be your biggest ally. I
will be out there with you every day.
So you really need to be careful
what you ask for. I get it.
You're coming from a place
where you don't want to be hurt.
Nobody wants to be hurt, right? Everybody
has had bad shits said about them.
Everyone's got something they're
insecure about. Everyone's got it.
But believe me, the idea that the
government is going to solve that problem,
it is not the way to go.
Did we get anywhere there?
I kind of felt good about that.
No, we didn't get anywhere. Okay.
We didn't get anywhere. I think maybe
I got somewhere with a couple of ideas.
That's all right. Um, this is why
conversation is so important guys. Right?
Like we can just kind of yell at each
other and this is what's happening and
this is what the media wants us to do.
You know,
you can turn on CNN and no one in their
right mind is learning anything from
CNN. You turn on CNN and you
get eight screens of yelling.
People who don't even know
how to tie their shoes,
telling you that they know how to run
the world. It's all nonsense. Actually.
The best way to watch CNN, put it on mute
and put the looney tunes theme song on,
um, is far, far better than what
CNN is showing you. But all of,
but this is what, this is why you
guys have turned onto the online news.
However you get your news,
whether you're on the left and you may
be watched TYT or you're on the right and
you'll listen to Ben Shapiro
or whatever else it is,
that there is a beautiful thing there.
It is now on you guys to
figure out what you believe,
find sources that you care about.
If you think that Dave Rubin is a bigoted,
hateful, whatever, don't watch.
I mean that's the beauty.
You don't have to show up.
You don't have to support. I mean
it's a, it's a beautiful thing.
I mean this is what the exchange of
freedom is all about. Um, I feel I could,
I could keep going here,
but I'm kind of tempted to just jump
right into the questions because it seems
like some of you guys have some
questions and I truly happy to.
We could start with all people that
disagree with everything I said here.
So how are we doing the questions?
I think there's a couple
of microphones around here,
so we've got some mics up there.
So if you've got a question and we've
got one down here, please come on down.
We can start with you right there.
I feel like you've got something for me.
Yeah. Yeah. Let's roll.
I'll just stand here.
Hold it free speech,
but he's going to hold the
mic for me. Okay. All right.
You can get unless you
want to. I mean, see,
so you see how silly you're coming in.
You're coming in. Ready, ready to fight.
Interesting that he's holding the mic.
All right. Why don't you give her the mic?
Let's, let's, why don't you pass me?
[inaudible]
big wind. Big Wind. Okay. I was
serious about the suit by the way.
So you don't believe hate
speech exists? No. And you,
the Supreme Court agrees
with me by the way. Great.
You and the rest of the people who are
here with you or who are supposed to be
here with you claim that people have
a victimhood complex and that anything
regarding racism or sexism or whatever
it is that we're talking about is fake
news and everybody is just out
here wanting to be a victim,
as if that's something you know
that people are spending spinal.
I wake up every morning and I say,
wow,
how can I be a be a victim despite
Dave Rubin or Charlie Kirk?
I just want to understand,
I just want to understand
like what does it take for,
for you know,
folks on your end of the Io to understand
that people have lived experiences and
who wake up every day,
every single day in this country,
whether you think the victim had complex
is real or not and they don't feel like
a part of this country.
And you can sit and blame all you want.
But this campus is a
great example right here.
When we have people on this campus who
are claiming that it is all sunshine and
rainbows and they have the
administration on their side.
And then the reality is
that biased incidents,
reports and hate crimes have gone up.
Yes.
And people have been spit on and people
have been threatened and people have
been told to go home to their country
even though they were born in fucking New
Jersey.
Yeah.
So I just want to understand where's
the like do like do I have to get lunch?
Like does somebody have to like murder me?
Like does somebody have to like,
so there's Tony basically harass me.
What would it take for it to be hate
speech and when do I actually become a
victim when I'm dead? Okay.
All right. Great question.
Great question. That's great.
[inaudible]
all right. It's a great
question. So first off,
the supreme court has ruled that hates
beached as an exist in that you can do
basically you can say whatever you
want short of yelling fire in a crowded
theater or calling for
direct violence to someone.
So right now you can say anything to me.
You can literally say anything to me.
I'm sure you're thinking of
a couple things and you can
say whatever you want to
be in, guess what? I'll, I'll survive.
And that's the price that you have
to pay to live in a free society.
So let me kick it back to you
for a second. So first off you,
there was a little miscommunication
in the way you presented that,
which is racism exists.
I don't think racism doesn't exist.
Of course there are bigoted people,
there are people who are buyer are
misogynists that may not like you because
you're a woman. There are people
that are, are don't like gay people.
So they won't like me.
There are people that are truly prejudice
against black people in every other
situation.
The idea that the government can come in
and manage and fix all of those things
is crazy.
And we live in a society that has done
more to free more people than any other
society,
truly in the history of the world.
But I will kick it back to you
for a second. So tell me about,
tell me about your oppression.
I mean,
tell me about what you are dealing
with and how the government can fix it.
It doesn't mean that bad people don't
exist, but tell me about your oppression.
Maybe.
Maybe we can work through something.
That's my favorite song.
Yeah.
Well that one was legit. It was
your mom. Nice. Alright, I have you.
Tell me about your work
oppression.
What if all,
I have no reason to sit and talk about
my own oppression because that's just
like mental energy. Well, I'm
going to be paid to talk about my,
hey ladies,
ladies. Ladies, I'll gladly take
your question if I May. I have.
We established that already. Okay, so,
so far we have some repetitive droning
statements and then when I take it back
to someone to ask about their oppression,
she wants to be paid for it.
You know what I, let me see what I got
here. Why don't you pay pal me? Yeah.
Well let me see what I can
do here. Venmo me, I got,
let's see what I got here.
Hi Violet.
Violet,
20 bucks. I got 20 bucks. I will pay.
You will pay you.
Okay,
so what would you prefer? What would
you prefer? That the government,
okay guys, I get it. I don't want
people to say bad things easier.
I wish I could get off to the sound of
my own voice. Wouldn't that be awesome?
You seem to get off the sound of your
own voice. Spam seal. You're angry,
you're angry, and there's no
reason to be angry. You're,
you're standing in front of that angry.
You're standing in front of someone.
That's truly, that comes from the
place that you are in right now.
I was a lefty my entire life.
I get it.
I get interesting how you've put
up political label on me already.
All right. All right, let's
go. Let's move on. We tried,
but really if you want to tell me your
impression, I'll give you 20 bucks.
I was mainly doing this. The ball. Yeah.
So easy with you guys.
Don't tell you what's that.
Oh,
she saw us in another 20 on right?
We got 40 bucks for you.
What are you doing here? Whoa,
Whoa, whoa. Don't you have hobby?
I have a first amendment right to
be here and actually part of the,
part of the freedom,
part of the freedom and the contractual
exchange we have is free people living
in a free society is that you're not
supposed to use your free speech to drown
out someone else's. So I'm truly asking
you, I am truly so I just want to know.
I just,
again,
I know this boundary where someone else's
free speech is infringing on your free
speech.
You went you those boundaries literally
infringes on other people's existence.
I just know it, but slam, just bouncy. See
where you end up being. So look you have,
I told you what the boundaries are.
The boundaries are,
you can't yell fire in a crowded
theater and you can't call directly for
violence, but short of that you
are allowed in a free society.
So I just have a quiet, would prefer those
people, their background. What's that?
Who I,
what's your background?
Some ridiculous [inaudible]
the question again.
And you are Jewish, correct? Yeah. So
I abhor anti Semitism.
So by your own like standard logic,
people can see shit about the Jews. Yeah.
You're allowing,
you're allowing family on both sides
of my family die in the Holocaust and I
grew up around Holocaust.
The speech that is espoused against
Jewish people does not promote violence
against them. You are allowed
to, in a free society,
I would prefer that people be
nicer. Right? I look for somebody,
a spouse, antisemitism, and that
may or may not lead to violence.
Again, handling claw hall for violence
to people. But what you can do,
it's the exchange of freedom.
Would you prefer,
I think there's a correlation between
hating Jews and wanting to kill them.
Yes or no question. You're asking
me quick. All right, let's move on.
Yes or no, right? You're like
a hostage situation over here.
I can't believe that's like,
I'm not.
I would,
I would prefer that people not say bad
shit about Jews or bad shit about Muslims
or gay people or anyone, but
the freedom, yes or no question.
What was the question? The question
is question and his are so tolerant.
You guys are such good guys.
You're such good. Okay.
It's so fascinating that you cleaned
the left has a victim complex.
Anytime somebody yells at you,
you also put on the victim complex.
I'm not anybody's who's victim of mine,
who's a victim of my who's victim,
and I don't want anything from you.
I want you to live your life in
peace. Go, go live your life in peace.
I don't want anything from you and I
don't want any bit. Yeah. All right,
let's move on.
Do you believe that people
who say they hate Jews?
I believe pill not be likely
to want to attack Jews.
Jewish man. I'm really
shocked. They might be,
but you have the right to say
mean things in a free society.
Do you think antisemitism is just
a man thing? Should we go like,
can I go to hit lows grave and tell him,
you know, it was just all a mean thing.
Can Wow.
Can you can go to Hillary's grave
until a dead person that he was mean.
You can. That's freedom.
I really in the grave,
that's what I can tell you right now.
Yeah.
My ancestors who who died in the
genocide are rolling in their graves
to violence or listen that we've
done it called me pathetic.
Yeah.
No.
Oh antisemetic when I'm saying
hate speech against Jews will lead to
violence. All right, well let's move on.
Let's more, I'm happy to do, I literally
do this with, I just have a question like,
like what's supposed to be having
a civil discourse? Like why,
why do you want me to shut up?
I thought this was civil discourse.
You know as years a couple hundred
people here that all would love to share
their thoughts. Not a couple
of hundred. I think I get.
How are we doing right here? Here, here.
Why don't we give this lady the make
right here in the red right here. Let's,
let's mix it up. All right guys.
Other people have questions.
Let's move on. See, this is the palm. You,
you're not oppressed. You're entitled.
I hope not.
You know what's [inaudible] here?
Nobody came here for
you. Sit Down Right now.
I know what I have said. Have
I cleaned? I'm oppressed.
So you just put those words in my mouth.
All right. Bye Bye. Okay. Okay, go ahead.
I'm here practicing my
first amendment right.
I'm going to give the Mike out of respect
to whoever wants to shit talk to you.
Now when I put this mic down,
I just want you to know that your
opinion literally means bullshit to me.
And if you agree with the concept,
yeah, I have a right to say it,
so I'm gonna say it so you have
a right to offend them out.
Let me get this straight.
Let me get this straight
personal vendetta against my character.
I'm not going after people. Ah,
so you've been playing the laws of
society and telling people who they can
offend and who they can offend and when
and when they can't even eat can offend
anybody.
But those are huge difference between now
you're Jewish or block and
just normally being offended.
I don't want anyone to die because they're
Jewish or not saying that you're that
[inaudible] speech.
You are invoicing. Yeah. I don't think
you know what to facto it means either,
but I just read a lot.
You know that I am a double major and
I do research actual organization.
Great. You literally and do not know who
I am. I don't know who you are. Not Right.
I don't either. You know what's
fascinating? Yeah. I have not gone,
I have not said a single thing about your
personal character up until this point.
You have belittled me. Said that I
don't understand what words mean.
Have told me to shut up.
I've told me that I'm taking up space.
Isn't that fascinating?
So who really is the intolerant ones?
Cause all I've done is just talk pretty
loudly on a mic as you have a problem on
the boom and talking
pretty loudly on a mic.
[inaudible]
somebody else can get a Preston
because I so gracious. Need,
we've been free speech. Yeah. Yeah. It's
all good. It's all good guys. This is,
this is what it's all about. Really
tailor. This is what it's all about.
It's our strawberry.
I have a plan
notice in the free society that we
live in. No one's coming for you now.
You can post that on Twitter.
You can do whatever you want.
It's a beautiful thing.
Yeah. Hey Dave, a big fan. Um,
just want to say start up before
I get to the question is that, um,
my parents came from Afghanistan.
They escaped the day before the
Russians invaded Christmas of 1979.
Um, so they all live in America now.
Uh, they love it. They'd never leave.
Um, and every day growing up,
uh, you know, I not every day,
you know, there's sometimes like
my skin's a little bit darker.
I grew up in a very white neighborhood.
I got some offhand comments about me
being Afghany terrorist jokes, everything.
I was like, all right, whatever. That's
how I, that's how I dealt with it. I said,
whatever,
I didn't internalize my oppression as
some people thought may think I did.
I just really didn't care because
they're going to make jokes.
They're really not going to go that far
because people are truly intolerant.
I don't think they're gonna
really go anywhere in life.
So that's what I'm saying about that is
if you're truly people who were in truly
intolerant aren't really
going to get anywhere.
And so I just don't let
that stuff bother me. Um,
but I wanted to ask about Marcus
Meechan. Do you know him? Um,
the account dangler the guy who, oh yeah,
yeah, yeah. I just wanted to ask like, Eh,
how ridiculous do you think it is for
a joke about that turning a pug into a
Nazi? However Duke is do they
get is that man was arrested.
His life was put on hold for two
years. Like I, it was just, it's insane
to me. Like it's completely insane. So
are you all familiar with this story?
So this is a, an online youtube comic, uh,
who basically he was doing a joke,
it was a joke and he had his,
his dog do the Hitler salute. Now
again, I am not for the Hitler salute.
I am not for Nazis.
I am not for white supremacism or racism
of any kind or anything like that.
But the guy made a joke and you can say
it's a shitty joke. He's a bad comic.
It's a tasteless joke, all of those
things. But in a free society,
you have a right to do those things.
You have a right to offend.
It is on you as the person
on the receiving end of
that to decide whether that
is going to ruin your day or make you
stronger in what your beliefs are or
anything else. So it's, by the way, the,
the real issue with this is
every one of us, every one of us,
even if you just hate me,
every one of us should be thanking
whatever you believe in that we are here,
we have the protections. He would have
been able to do that in the United States.
Now,
you may not like it again,
but we have the protections that allow
you to live your life to the maximum
potential in this country.
We live in a place that a young guy
whose parents came from Afghanistan award
and torn country can come here and not
make excuses and do everything that you
want to do in your life and
you're going to do amazing things.
I have no doubt about it.
That is a beautiful thing.
You have no desire to play the victim.
You're going to go out there
and bust your ass and yes,
will there be someone that you might
want to work for that's going to go, wow,
he's got brown skin and I'm a racist
and I'm not going to hire him.
That might happen. It might, but you
know what? Someone else will find you.
And the more that these companies,
if there was a big company
out there that's saying,
we're not going to hire this person or
that person based on skin color or based
on race, they will crumble. Look what's
happening in Silicon Valley right now.
It's actually amazing. It's amazing what's
Peter Thiel is leaving Silicon
Valley because leftist, uh,
you got to work on getting that.
Oh, she's got a backup. Um,
it's incredible [inaudible]
leaving silicon valley
because leftism has caused a
situation where they
cannot even think straight.
They cannot come up with new ideas.
That's why there were no new apps.
Where's the new Twitter? Where's the
new snapchat? Where's the new Facebook?
We can't come out of the group thing.
So whatever you want to do in your life,
you're going to do great
things. I have no doubt. Yeah.
Why don't we go right here.
Red Jacket right here.
Yup.
Mike,
my question is,
you're trying to lead a civil discourse
day of it and why is it that some people
believe that it's okay to be disrespectful
in interrupt so that some of us can't
hear the presentation and hear other
questions and hear your views on things?
Yeah, I mean, I don't know
that I'm the right guy to be
asking that. I will gladly,
I will gladly talk to all of these
people. I mean, really that's how you,
the way you change your mind,
the way you change minds guys,
is you sit with people and you
try to explain your position.
Not trying to drown out people.
I mean that's just,
that's just how it's done in every,
in every sale.
What's that?
You can, yes you can. You're
right. No, but you're right.
You can do it. Notice no one's coming
for you. Nobody's coming for you.
No one's you.
Do you have a question or a comment?
Yeah. All right. I mean,
this is what happens every time and the
but partly what's going on here guys,
is that the reason to critically
think has become so deg degradated.
Okay.
The reason it's become so,
so hurtful to hear words is because
the left has owned all of the places of
learning for so long that every
time someone comes in and says,
I believe in low taxes,
or I believe in something that's a
little bit out of leftist mainstream,
people immediately think that means you
were racist or bigoted or homophobic or
something, and it's, it's
simply isn't the truth.
Learn how to sit with people in a free
society who are a little bit different
than you learn how to sit with
people and change their minds,
but if you think changed,
you're going to change people's minds by
drowning them out. It just doesn't work.
You may get some temporary wins,
right?
You can get some applause and
you can get some temporary wins,
but you will not win in the long term
because you will create a society that
simply will not be tolerant of you one
day because one day you will be on the
other side of it and there will be a
young person that believes in something
that you don't believe in
or believe something that
you think is hate speech and
they will come for you too.
And the only way, the only way,
the only way to ensure protections for
everybody is to make sure that we're all
treated equally under the law. And that's
what, that's what we've got right now.
We've got two more moves from a
white guy over here. What else?
Where are we right over here.
Sorry. Oh, sorry. Um, hi.
So I just had a question just cause I
want to clarify what you said earlier
about how you think we
shouldn't be passing laws
against like speech that could
be hateful or is hateful or whatever
just because it's limiting people's
freedoms.
But I think what I wanted to ask was,
so when you say like limiting
free speech to some degree,
do you think that could mean that you,
once you pass one law that's
limiting one thing for free speech,
then it could turn into,
oh then you're limiting another thing
for free speech and then you like have
this whirlwind of,
then you live in a society where people
just can't say anything because I feel
like it's too,
I guess what's the word I want to use?
It's like up in the air to say that
you can say you can't say this thing.
You can say that thing like absolutely
government has to take a very like
Mitt.
Like you can't just lean on.
I'm trying to say will offend you as a
human being is different than what will
offend me.
So you can't have subjective laws or
leave it up to the mob or to special
interests or any other group to say,
okay,
this is the group of people
we can't say anything about.
Or these are the words you can't say or
these are the people that you account
can't accidentally Miss Gender.
And again,
I say all of that within the framework
of you should and hopefully will be
respectful to people.
You will hopefully treat
people as individuals and be
willing to have friends of
all colors and,
and all of that
stuff.
You guys have a question?
Do you have a question?
You have a question.
Are you guys the problem?
I think, I think you got the point there.
I think you have to play there. Yes,
it is a slippery slope. If you say, okay,
can't say this about x,
someone else is going to say you
can't say they see you there. Okay.
And then I feel like you
could get to a point where
it's just like nothing can be said and I
feel like that's, you actually have you,
you are the problem. You
got, you almost got it.
You almost got it.
You almost got it except for the word not.
Can we try that one?
See? Do you have a question? Perhaps.
Question Group think man, it's
alluring. Alright, we can move on.
We can move on.
I was just gonna say that I feel like
it's once you opened the door for one
thing,
it can be very dicey to enforce things
without infringing on rights because then
you could say that like, oh was saying
everyone should be equal as wrong.
If you had like for example if you had
like a lot of people are concerned that
Trump is a white supremacists because
they were play the quiet game.
You're the quiet game.
Let's see how long you can do it.
If you have people saying like Trump's
a racist, Trump's a white supremacist,
which is like a very fair point to say
because I disagree with like a ton of
this shit. He says he says
like this stupid ass shit ever.
But if those people get in like the
majority of government and then they're
passing laws saying that you
can't preach for equality,
you can't say these things.
Like I feel like it's,
you can't just have these objective laws,
which I like.
That's why we are trying to make,
because you're completely right,
like if you're pushing for
people to make subjective laws,
like hate speech is always wrong,
but then if you have like this majority
sashes like oh totally racist group in
place,
then they're going to try to pass.
Oh well you can say everyone can be equal.
Oh now we're going to have like
white supremacists laws in places.
I like the point you're trying to make.
That is the point I'm trying to make.
You can't,
you can't base laws on subjectivity.
You have to base laws on a quality.
We should have laws in this country that
make every single person in this room
equal. It is as simple
as that. What's that?
Equality does not exist.
Okay,
so can you give me a give me a question
or something that I can respond to that
and I'll,
I'll gladly do that.
What?
What, what, what,
what was the question? You're,
you're allowed. I said I you,
you asked me several times
and I repeatedly said yes.
You're allowed to say hateful things.
It sucks,
but you're allowed to say hateful
things that that's what happens. Okay.
Where are we
down here, James? No,
here we go here and then over there.
Okay.
Someone have a question over here?
Hey Dave, how's it going? I'm
actually a pretty liberal dude.
A lot of my friends are in turning points
site. I came to help them out, but hey,
she knows who your friends
are, not these. Um,
so what I,
a lot of this event was supposed to be
surrounding cultural appropriation. Yeah.
Um, and I know that you didn't maybe
get a chance to really dive into that.
I know you talked about like the,
the overarching themes of regarding
the importance of free speech. Yup. Um,
but I know that there's,
there's a lot of, uh,
differences when it comes to a college
campus and how people feel and I know
that on this campus, um, you know,
we can have our disagreements about what
cultural appropriation means or what
role it plays. Um, but there
have been bias incidents.
I think there's been,
uh, you know, things.
Yeah. The things that have happened
that have stemmed from racism and,
and I know that this,
it shouldn't be a government
policy maybe to be implemented,
but what steps do you think
the administration can
take to make sure that we
feel safe but also just as if
not more equally important?
Um, people have the right to free
speech, right? To think what they want.
Well,
I think the only thing that the government
can do is sort of what it has done
generally, which is make sure
that we all have equal laws.
You can't have laws that say x people
can do this and why people can do this.
It's why marriage equality was a
just thing they wanted equal rights,
not separate rights. As for
cultural appropriation, I
mean I would, I would say,
do you think you should be allowed
to put dreadlocks in your hair?
Yes.
Well, so, so my understanding
of it was more to it.
The answer is yes.
You can do whatever you want.
You can do whatever you want with
your body. You are, it is your body.
It's not their body. You can
do whatever you want. Now.
You can be respectful if you feel that's
going to offend people and you want to
know more about the history of dread
locks and all that. But you if you,
if you pass,
if you pass the capacity.
Okay,
so I've never heard of that.
I would think that that's completely
separate if that's what you're,
I don't know about that specific instance.
So you're telling me you're giving me
an antidotal story that a hospital hired
white with dreadlocks,
but not a black person with dreadlocks.
I would need to know more about that
story, but if you want to send me a link,
I'll gladly look at it. I
mean, I'll gladly look at it.
Of course the hospital shouldn't
be looking at someone's skin color.
So,
so what is what, so what is your, what
is your solution? What is your solution?
Yeah, the solution is all you can do is
create the conditions for more freedom.
And hopefully you can educate people
to be better. That's all you can do.
What so, yeah. So you have to treat,
you have to show people what freedom is.
Just
just to build off the points.
I mean my understanding was that cultural
appropriation and especially the,
the debates that we've had over at here,
yeah.
Stemmed more from intentionally putting
people down or attacking people that
wear a lot of the frustration I
think has come from. Yeah. Um,
my question I guess was
more directed to you.
Do you think that a university has a
little bit more of a role to play? Um,
then then the governor
in the university can have
a code of conduct, right.
Especially a private university can have
all sorts of codes of conduct and say
if you treat your fellow student this way
or you treat your fellow students that
way,
that we are not going to allow you to be
a part of this university or you won't
be able to be part of the
Greek system or whatever it is.
But also that's consistent
with everything else I believe,
which is that it should be about
local control. So you should ever,
in every situation,
the best way for you to be
governed is by your own community.
Every right. We shouldn't be handing off
everything to the federal government.
So I think one of the one,
what's that?
Huh?
You think you're doing right now?
Right now,
if it was up to the states,
we would have slavery.
Yeah.
Well, yes. Yeah. Well,
I'll talk to you about it.
I'm going to deny the civil ward.
No, I'm not going to deny the civil
beauty of the states. I would
recommend, I would recommend a,
an interview I did with Randy Barnett,
who is a constitutional law
professor at Georgetown.
And what he talks about is the beauty
of the states is that because we have 50
states, you, if you don't like
what's happening in your state,
you can move to another state.
You can move to another state if you,
if California,
I live in California there.
Hold on.
[inaudible] what's that?
[inaudible]
I, I'm not even really sure where
we're debating here. I assure you,
I am against slavery.
I am 100% for equality for everyone.
So I don't, I don't know exactly what
we're, what we're debating here. Yeah.
I [inaudible] right on brother.
Right. Why don't we go this way?
Go down here.
Yeah.
Could I just hear your
thoughts on intellectual
royalism intellectual pluralism
and that we should have a
plethora of ideas. Yeah.
Every idea should be able to compete in
the market. Yes, of course. Of course.
I'm for all of these people
expressing their ideas,
what you can't do is just drown out
other people from expressing theirs.
All right.
Yeah.
Okay. I mean, I'm for
anything. I mean, look,
you could tell me we could sit there and
anyone here is welcoming and that's why
we do Q and A's,
right?
It's for anyone to share their views and
then I can share my views and then you
go back and forth and then you
figure out what the best ideas are.
That's the beauty of free speech.
No one,
I'm not here to teach you guys what
to think if you disagree with me.
That's great. I just want us to be able
to live in the same society together.
I mean that,
that's it.
We should have the same laws so that
we can exist in the same society.
But of course, of course we should
worry about to be debating ideas.
Yeah.
Yes. Joe Being on the
left, being progressive's,
do you feel threatened
when you leave here? Well,
generally speaking in America in 2018
the left an Antifa is more violent than
the same version on the right. Yeah, but
I'm not, I don't think you're going to do,
I don't think you're going
to do anything to me.
You don't seem to like me very much.
[inaudible]
I'm not a victim. I'll be all
right. I mean, I'm pretty quick.
I can move on my feet.
I'll be all right. Yeah.
I don't think you are going to.
Yeah,
I don't think any,
I don't think there's any
reason to believe that any
of the people who have sat
here respectfully and quietly,
so you think people outside are going
to come for the people in this room
on a regular basis actually
attacked people of color I do.
Or minorities or people
that are transgender. Right.
And we have laws against all of those
things as we should, as we should,
as we should.
[inaudible] so
we have laws about those things.
I mean, it doesn't mean that
it doesn't mean that
the system is perfect.
It doesn't mean that the
system is perfect, but we
have laws about those things.
Um, I really don't have a question
for you because you don't answer them,
so I'm just going to say this.
MMM.
You said you said La Ronda, um,
discipline quarter, boom, guys,
hate speech was not a thing,
but we know discipline cost plus a fee,
faggots scene.
They would for a dred Scott and the hood
for a ton of things that pretty much
put people of color and people of color
across the United States in jeopardy.
They've made this feel like second class
citizens and it's actually legalized
slavery.
They did a lot of discipline codes,
did a lot of things that
make people of color in this,
in this United States feel like
they were not part of the country.
So when you talk about how,
um, when you talk about this,
because doing this and doing
that and showing that, um,
when you talk about this,
we've got to saying that we don't add
that there is no such thing as, as, um,
when you call it again as hate speech,
it doesn't make any sense because it's
of course has no more style than if
they've been moving things that are wrong,
which means that you have no point
bringing up the supreme courts as a moral
standards of saying that something exists
when it doesn't because it's would be
code does not rule anything that
makes any sense anymore. Well there,
there was a lot of things in
there that I didn't quite say,
but I would agree that the supreme
court in and of itself is not the moral
arbiter and absolutely,
they absolutely can. Well,
because we're a nation of laws, we can
debate. We can debate. Hold on, hold on.
I let you ask.
So yeah. Yes.
So just moving back on the first time
when you came in and when you started
talking, you talked about
how we had the, the, the,
the statue of liberty and how does such
a deliverance, he said big into your ma,
your poor masses heard the message
and they were separate. They mean,
and then you went further on to say that
we shouldn't have an open bar there and
we should allow illegal immigrants into
the country, which is basically just
you're contradicting yourself. And then
you talked about Canada's always and I,
you said how can this always was being
supported by chaos and how that's a great
thing. And He, I've,
there's a youtube video of John can just
always talking about how celebrities,
you're not fucking speak because she
doesn't care about their opinions.
So basically you standing there and you
say something that is super critical
because they can just watch you're
talking about doesn't take the celebrities
have the right to speak,
which means that you should even be
using waste as a moral standard or
discipline quarters in
neuroscience because all these
people are people we know.
That used to be shit.
So what you're saying would you be saying
so far is based on crap cause it makes
no fucking sense. My friend, I, I assume
you didn't watch my show this week.
I did a video a,
I did a video about how you can't
take kinase word for Gospel,
but what he did do was give a little room.
He gave wait a little bit.
This is the, he might find
Chris, I let you speak.
So let me answer you and then we'll,
we'll do it again. So that he,
that Kanye offered a little oxygen for
people to think a little bit differently
in the video that I did
just a few days ago. I said,
I don't know what his political beliefs
are and he might say something crazy
tomorrow. So you can't take him
as if he's the no. All in the end.
All and the be all though. I
bring him up. Well because people,
because ideas matter. People matter.
He's a, whether you like Kanye or not,
he's a mover of culture. He's
someone that moves culture. Wow. No,
I think the,
the,
the basic thing in this room right now
is that we have people like you who go
around talking about things
they have no clue about.
You pretty good handle on this
stuff. So you, you don't, you don't,
you pretty much they'll understand the
plight of people of color across the
country. So why do we have that? That
is a against you. That's not against me.
Really. Yeah. Really. So
for example, um, there were,
there was a case of a student
athletes, um, Tuesdays athletes,
the committee that they had the rape case.
One was black and one was white.
One good three months in changes.
The other one got 18 years.
So that shows you the one who got his
fingers was black at home. We Myers White,
white people, excuse me, excuse
me, white people in this country.
I've been known to get less sentences for
the same clients coming to us as black
people. So that shows that the justice
system in itself is basically flows,
which means reforming the justice system.
I've done plenty of videos about that too.
But you're just saying
that we have the rock.
So what's the whole point of before,
why would you want to read
from a law that works?
You basically speaking from
two sides of your mouth,
you don't know what you're talking about.
We
listen my friend, I am completely
down. Okay. We're not friends.
Fine. I am completely down to
reform the prison justice system.
I am completely down to reform that
because I asked you because laws and the
justice system are not exactly the same
thing.
[inaudible] love it.
No, well you're talking about is that
perhaps black people don't have access to
better lawyers because of sociopath
anomic reasons and a zillion other
things. No, it's not that. Okay.
Okay. All right. How you doing? Good.
Yep.
Yeah.
Can I hold it?
All right. Hi. Hi. Um,
so I know that you mentioned that our
country was not founded on identity
politics. However, I want to note that
women, people of color and other, my,
my July's identities were not written
into history and therefore in the
foundation of our country for that matter.
So my question here is how do you think
everyone is equal and represented if
this country was founded on
the premises of exclusion?
So [inaudible] no,
so I, I've talked about
this a lot. Look, is there,
is there any question that George
Washington, Thomas Jefferson,
that many of the other
founders owned slaves.
Thomas Jefferson owned
slaves until the day he died.
He had an affair with at least one
slave while at the very w wait, hold on.
While at the very same time,
while at the very same time he was writing
the laws that ultimately would free
the slaves. So is he
a, is he a perfect man?
Is he a perfect man? He is not
George Washington. The day died, his,
his half of the slaves were freed,
but Martha Washington kept her half.
Is that just, is that just, is that right?
No, but these people, I would say this,
go to the Jefferson Memorial in DC.
It's a little off the beaten path and,
and read and read those documents there.
And these flawed people who are just,
people have their time.
They were writing the documents that
would ultimately give more freedom to more
people than any other country
in the history of the world.
It doesn't mean it doesn't mean,
it doesn't mean that they were always
right and it doesn't mean that they,
that they didn't have their
own prejudices that, but they,
it means that they were people who
grew up in a certain time. And if, if,
if the goal is to always destroy the
history to make a future that you think is
better, you will lose a
lot by getting rid of that.
So I would say they were imperfect
people who wrote some laws and wrote the
basic foundation of the constitution and
the bill of rights that have guaranteed
more freedoms to more people
than anywhere else. I think.
Hi, last one, last one. Big Finish ruble.
Yep.
So,
um,
I just want to say real quick that
Thomas Jefferson was the third president,
right? And you're saying
that him in Washington, we
writing laws to free slaves,
but it wasn't until the 16th
president that those slaves wasn't,
you weren't even free around the 45th
president and we're still dying every day.
There was just a person that
was linked two days ago.
So I don't want to hear this
bullshit about hates me.
Do not freeze beach a quality exists.
Nothing because this, it does it for you.
It does.
Because you have privilege.
The fact that you can stand here and
talk about the fact that people can say
slurs to you at whatever and you
can just walk outside. It's okay.
No. If someone calls me
the n word, I can get shot.
So don't be telling me right now that it
doesn't exist and that's all I have to
say.
Okay,
I'm bad node.
All right? You know what Frito guys,
I've actually totally enjoyed this.
This is business one. It's all about that.
All right, settle down. You don't own me.
You know what I mean?
Relaxed Lady. Um, uh,
I've actually really enjoyed this.
This is what it's all about. And,
and whether you disagreed with
everything I said, are you agreed?
We did a little something here.
You know what? And, uh, and I hope,
I hope perhaps that I changed some of
your minds and perhaps some of those guys
change, change your minds. And either
way, either way, it's all good.
As long as we don't walk out of here at
each other's throats and hurting each
other than Ben. It's
actually, yeah, I don't sense.
I don't sense that any
of these calm people.
No problem.
All right, I'll grant you that guys, guys.
We're not gonna create any acts of
violence against any of these people here
tonight. All right, well, I
have enjoyed this for real.
Hopefully next time Candice in, uh, and
Charlie will join for the festivities and,
uh, where do people get a beer here in
New Hampshire? I'll find out about that.
All right.
Thank you guys.